on sera tous nous sommes le lundi 9 mai
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de cette fuite le
journal comme chaque jour nous revenons
sur votre actualité locale entouré de
nous inviter mais également des
journalistes de la rédaction
suite on commence avec les titres de
cette édition le 9 mai l'ensemble des
états membres de l'union européenne
célèbre la journée de l'europe date de
commémoration du discours de schuman le
9 mai 1950 pour l'occasion harlem désir
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes étaient dans les yvelines à
la maison où jean monnet à bazoches sur
guyonne nous y reviendrons et ce
dimanche la france commémorait lasri le
71e anniversaire de la victoire des
alliés sur l'allemagne nazie et la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale à magny
les hameaux un livre infinie a été créée
par des collégiens pour cette occasion
une tradition de la ville depuis bientôt
12 ans et enfin pour finir le premier
temple mormon de france métropolitaine
va voir le jour à la frontière de
versailles et du chéné débuter en 2013
les travaux sont sur le point d'être
achevés siens et je vous le disais en
titre aujourd'hui le 9 mai l'ensemble
des états membres de l'union européenne
célèbre la journée de l'europe date de
commémoration du discours de schuman le
9 mai 1950 pour l'occasion harlem désir
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes s'est rendu dans les
yvelines à la maison jean monnet à
bazoches sur yonne où il a rencontré des
lycéens williams elle était sur place
c'est ici il ya 66 ans dans cette maison
jean monnet rédiger la déclaration
historique que robert schuman à les
adresser à l'europe le 9 mai 1960 un
symbole de l'origine de l'union
européenne qui est venu visiter harlem
désir pour célébrer la fête de l'europe
jean monnet a inventé ce qui est devenu
la commission européenne serre d'une
haute autorité a qui ont délégué à sa
fin on me le pouvoir et c'est de là que
sont nées toutes les autres politiques
européennes
la politique agricole commune le marché
commun
la politique du commerce etc et puis
finalement la monnaie commune et
l'europe que le connaissant jean nuit au
programme visite de la maison avec
l'association jean monnet et membre du
parlement européen une fête de l'europe
qui intervient dans un contexte
particulier où l'union européenne
rencontrent des difficultés face aux
grandes crises économiques et
migratoires
il faudra que ceux qui croient à l'idée
européenne ne se laisse pas intimider
par les populistes par les anti
européens par les nationalistes et
proposent au contraire de renforcer
cette maison commune parce que si on la
renforce pas effectivement elle paraît
inefficace et à ce moment là on alimente
encore plus le scepticisme est donc si
on veut répondre au mieux aux grands
défis de l'économie de l'emploi mais
aussi de la sécurité de la crise des
réfugiés
c'est au contraire par davantage de
coopération européenne
on le fera et et c'est ça qui les
vendent après la visite le secrétaire
d'état a fait face aux élèves du lycée
hélène boucher de tremblay en france
pourquoi le parlement européen et qui
l'exclût de la politique européenne
une véritable conférence de presse menée
par des adolescents qui avaient
soigneusement préparé leurs questions
ballet rap en fait c'est notre c'est
notre futur en fait on n'a pas que comme
parents comme par exemple le ministre
lui l'avait pas commencé il avait pas
pensé à lui pas sa génération mais la
pension générations futures donc c'est
tout comme nous en fait on a pensé aussi
à notre génération figure de plus tard
en fait tendance à avoir
oui la maintenance et nous ils ont fait
pour nous et nous on va faire pour les
autres
pour illustrer ses propos le secrétaire
d'état a ensuite été convié à la
plantation d'un arbre avec les lycéens
un symbole de cette construction commune
et à la frontière de versailles et du
chéné un temple mormon est en train de
voir le jour sera le premier en france
métropolitaine débuter en 2013 les
travaux sont sur le point d'être achevé
près de 100 adeptes pourront être
accueillis au sein de l'établissement
leur permettant notamment de se marier
l'église mormone l'église de
jésus-christ des saints des derniers
jours est une religion chrétienne né aux
états unis
1830 mélanie poké nous en dit plus
regardées 110 églises à travers toute la
france mais pas encore de temple c'est
aux chaînés qui prend forme d'une
surface de 6000 240 mètres carrés
il pourra accueillir jusqu'à 100 adeptes
par jour il permettra aussi aux
pratiquants de se marier
nous avons une église à versailles qui
permet à tous les mormons de la région
des yvelines de se réunir chaque
dimanche d'avoir des activités
récréatives des réunions administratives
pour le fonctionnement la paroisse mais
nous avons un seul temple parce que le
temple c'est un lieu de rencontre entre
l'homme et dieu c'est un peu comme un
monastère
le temple est financé par le siège de
l'église mormone situer cette lake city
aux états unis les pratiquants versant
10 % de leurs revenus
quatre recours ont été déposés devant le
tribunal administratif et une pétition
avait été lancée contre la construction
entamés en 2013 on comprend que tout le
monde puisse s'exprimer
émettre un avis sur la construction d'un
tel bâtiment
ceci étant dit chacun à la liberté de
pouvoir partager ses remarques mais
néanmoins nous avons besoin d'un temple
en france pour nous pouvoir nous
recueillir et assister à nos à nos
réunions dans ce temple l'église mormone
revendique près de 40000 pratique en
france métropolitaine
ils sont 500 dans les yvelines la fin
des travaux est attendu pour la fin de
l'année 2016 ou le premier semestre 2010
est et le projet de loi travail de la
ministre myriam el khomri est en ce
moment examiné par l'assemblée nationale
étudiants salariés mais aussi syndicats
comme la cgt le medef tous sont opposés
à cette loi les artisans eux aussi sont
opposés au projet de loi travail pour
nous en parler ce soir en plateau de
cyril euros qu'on saura vous merci merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation là vous
êtes administrateur de luppé a donc lu
nulle pour les artisans à des yvelines
alors selon vous ce projet de loi porte
atteinte aux petites entreprises et
notamment aux artisans pourquoi vous
nous en dire un peu plus il ya plusieurs
raisons
au départ c'est un projet de loi qui a
été étudié sans prendre contact avec les
organisations professionnelles
patronales artisanale et on voit bien
qu'on a été totalement oublié et que ce
texte a été construit au départ pourrait
avec le medef c'est des textes qui vont
dans le sens des grandes entreprises
mais qui sont complètement inadaptés à
nos entreprises artisanales donc dans sa
conception d'origine où il y avait
énormément de sujets sur lesquels nous
étions contre le principal étant la
parité entre les entreprises artisanales
et des grosses entreprises sur laquelle
la représentativité ce qu'on appelle la
représentativité ou les entreprises du
medef était reconnu et nous complètement
oublié isolées et sans plus aucun
pouvoir de décision dans l'est dans les
décisions paritaire fonde qu'on doit
prendre avec les salariés donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui est en train de se
régler
néanmoins il ya encore énormément
d'articles sur lesquels nous ne pouvons
pas travailler et accepter qu'ils soient
appliquées dans entreprises la
surtaxation des cdd on voit bien que
c'est quand même quelque chose qui va à
l'encontre du de l'emploi et pourtant on
est tous à la recherche de compétences
et à essayer de redonner à nos millions
de chômeurs ça c'est par exemple un
argument que bertrand de créer président
du medef des yvelines qui est venu au
plateau vous avez nous avait vendu
également on veut donc voilà la station
la surtaxation des cdd c'était aussi une
mauvaise chose pour le medef qu'ils
étaient opposés que du coup ça ne
permettait pas d'embaucher plus de
personnel vous êtes d'accord avec ça
vous a fait et c'est encore ce sera
encore plus flagrant là pour le coup
dans les entreprises artisanales ou
souvent on est à la limite d'embauché ou
pas et le chef d'entreprise il a souvent
cette envie de dire ben il faudrait que
j'ai ça il voir est-ce que ça amène plus
de productivité
est-ce que ça améliore mon chiffre
d'affaires et est ce que c'est un emploi
du coup que je peux pérenniser
aujourd'hui si on lui dit ah bah oui
mais au lieu de vous coûter 100 ça va
vous coûter 110 ou 115
ils valent pas le faire il va rester sur
sa réserve
on n'a pas suffisamment de visibilité
dans l'avenir pour pouvoir s'engager sur
des coup pareil alors pourtant ce projet
doit travailler sont ces voiles à
améliorer l'emploi ils censés combattre
le chômage on dit que les art et
l'artisanat c'est la première entreprise
de france ça ne va pas bouder n'y a
aucune mesure qui aiderait voilà à
embaucher plus dans ce projet la foi de
votre travail
actuellement non les entreprises
artisanales
c'est 98 % des entreprises en france c
est normal aurait certes on n'a pas 500
salariés on n'a pas mis long n'a pas
mille cinq cents c'est des petites
structures de 3 5 10 mais c'est nous qui
créons l'emploi c'est pas monsieur
gattaz avec son pin se dit un million
d'emplois
il s'est rien passé les emplois ils
viendront de l'artisanat est
effectivement trop de trop de points sur
ce projet de loi travail vont à
l'encontre de nos entreprises
alourdissent le fonctionnement de nos
entreprises
nous revendiquons la primauté des
accords de branche dans nos entreprises
elles sont à négocier nationalement avec
les organisations patronales avec les
organisations syndicales salariées ça
fonctionne très bien
aujourd'hui on souhaite créer des
accords d'entreprise sur chacun va
pouvoir décider un petit peu de son côté
de chaque entreprise en fait décédé
voilà deux son propre code du travail
avec ses services qui montrait beaucoup
beaucoup de travail en plus justement
pour les patrons du travail
la concurrence probablement un moment
déloyale parce que certains pourront de
par leur volume leur structure proposait
alors salariés des compensations
directes ou indirectes
et effectivement surtout une concurrents
et puis alors autant de codes de travail
que d'entreprises alors nos
revendications c'est est d'alléger le
code du travail et on est en train de le
complexifier en fait alors justement le
début de la doua des bulles
la loi vous étiez opposé il ya eu des
négociations depuis donc avec notamment
les étudiants avec aussi la cgt ces
négociations par exemple on fait
contraint le medef qui s'y est
totalement opposé vous de votre côté
c'est pareil vous restez toujours
opposée avec toi ou est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui ont peut-être changé qui ont
évolué depuis ces négociations les
négociations à part la représentativité
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure qui
vont on revient un peu dans les dents
des bornages qu'on pourrait accepter
il y avait un point fort qui était la
limitation des coûts aux prud'hommes de
quand on licencie un salarié
bon ça ça a été considérablement réduits
c'est plus qu un référentiel que les
juges pourront utiliser mais qui seront
pas obligés d'utiliser donc on met
encore une épée de damoclès au-dessus de
l'employeur en lui disant le jour où
vous aurez besoin éventuellement de
deux licenciés vous risquez un coût qui
n'est pas calculable
parce que ce sera la bonne volonté des
juges et c'est quand même pour nous une
clause aussi de nos embauches on voit
des collègues qui hésite
du fait de cette de cette contrainte
donc ça ça n'a pas été dans le bon sens
alors qu'au départ on avait une un
plafonnement de ces indemnités
vous prenez part également aux
négociations vous l'avais dit à côté du
medef de la cgpme
pourtant vous ne partagez pas
spécialement leur position le medef a
posé un ultimatum lui
est-ce que c'est pas aller trop loin
selon vous est-ce que vous allez adopter
cette même position justement de poser
un ultimatum si la loi ne vous satisfait
pas a priori non on n'est pas dans cette
dans cette position on espère toujours
que la négociation primera qu'on
arrivera à obtenir par la discussion en
expliquant l'échelon or en discussion
justement avec les parlementaires au
jour toujours tant que la loi sera pas
votée on restera attentifs et vindicatif
pour essayer de faire modifier de
déposer des amendements on le fait de
faire supprimer des articles le fameux
article 19 sur la représentativité avait
été par la commission a supprimé
aujourd'hui il est en cours de
renégociation du cou et à l'époque on
avait menacé effectivement de quitter la
table des négociations parce que c'était
inadmissible
sur les autres points voilà on préfère
on préfère rester autour de la table et
négocier et expliquer surtout ceux
souvent nos politiques ont ce défaut de
ne pas connaître l'entreprise va
connaître l'artisanat et on les
rencontre en ce moment régulièrement que
ce soit départementalement régionalement
et nationalement et on se rend compte
que quand on leur explique les choses
on arrive à faire bouger un petit peu
les lignes quand même on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui de la possibilité de deux
premiers l'article 49-3 pouvoir passer
la loi en force
est ce que ce sera un drame selon vous
pour les versions pour les entreprises
de france de ballons ça peut être quand
même ça peut être un gros problème
effectivement parce que je pense que ça
va confronter nos collègues l'inconnu
encore mais je crois qu'ils en ont
suffisamment on n'a pas de visibilité
d'activité on n'a pas de visibilité sur
la reprise sur la modification de la
conjoncture donc le ramener encore cette
incertitude
je pense que ça peut être encore un
risque de de frein à l'embauché de frein
à la prise d'apprentis est et vu ce qui
se passe actuellement que ce soit
patronales que ce soit les salariés que
ce soit les jeunes
il ya beaucoup quand même de voir un
contre cette loi et je pense que le tir
de 9,3 serait pas la bonne la bonne
solution
vous vous êtes mobilisés forcément
contre ce projet de loi travail est ce
que vous allez continuer ce que les des
actions prévues par l'ipea par les
artisans pour voilà s'opposer encore une
fois cette fois actuellement elle se
fait habituellement un chacun dans son
département jeudi dans sa région
voilà va au devant des acteurs c'est à
nos députés nos sénateurs pour
effectivement le cce qui vont avoir le
projet en main et qu'ils vont pouvoir
modifier les articles y introduire des
amendements
et c'est auprès d'eux qu'on fait ce
travail plutôt que dans la rue a
perturbé les citoyens une dernière
question avant de terminer cet entretien
est ce que justement voilà qu'est ce que
vous attendez aujourd'hui du
gouvernement faire marche arrière
refaire des négociations ou refaire un
nouveau projet de loi avec plus de
discussions entre les deux organisations
et le gouvernement
je pense que là on a été encore une fois
dans la précipitation
il faudrait remettre tout le monde
autour de la table les voir je pense il
ya des moyens de d'adapter ce projet de
loi tout n'est pas négatif
mais le problème c'est que les artisans
une partie qui ne connaissent pas le
medef une autre les salariés une autre
donc c'est un peu compliqué je pense que
c'est un travail qui aurait dû être fait
en amont
je comprends que le retirer c'est quand
même un désaveu pour le gouvernement
néanmoins il y avait quand même beaucoup
de points il ya beaucoup de choses à
bouger donc ça me semble compliqué de le
faire juste à la marche bien nous
suivons cette actualité merci beaucoup à
thierry lorho masque passons maintenant
à une autre
notre information ce dimanche la france
a commémoré le 71e anniversaire de la
victoire des alliés sur l'allemagne
nazie et la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale à magny les hameaux
un livre infinie a été créée par des
collégiens pour cette occasion une
tradition de la ville depuis douze ans
avec une nouveauté cette année la
créance la création par don d'un champ
par les élèves eux-mêmes une manière
d'honorer la mémoire des disparus
regardez ce reportage signé camille
lambert c'est le conflit le plus
meurtrier de l'histoire la seconde
guerre mondiale a fait plus de 50
millions de morts
dimanche 8 mai la france à commémorer le
70e anniversaire de la fin de cette
guerre en 1945
un rendez vous incontournable pour magny
les hameaux et pour ces élèves qui ont
réalisé comme chaque année un livre
infinie à cette occasion ils écrivent
les noms des morts pour la france magny
cours dans un livre qui est reproduit
chaque année et c'est la raison pour
laquelle donc il est infinie l'objectif
est vraiment de que la mémoire passe de
génération de génération originalité de
ce douzième tome du livre infinie les
élèves de 5e du collège albert einstein
ont également créé un champ leurs canons
à l'unisson a été chanté accompagnés
d'un orchestre lors de la cérémonie
devant les
lui et les habitants
les
on est parti de la symphonie numéro un
malheur le du troisième mouvement
je suis fier de ses élèves qui ont
vraiment donné beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie pour réaliser ils ont créé les
paroles en partenariat avec le
professeur de français professeur
d'histoire-géo les anciens combattants
sont intervenus en classe dans la
chanson il y a on commémore les morts en
fait on sait grave en fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé donc faut que tout le monde
s'en souvienne pour moi ce livre m'a
servi de d'apprendre parce que c'était
la guerre en précision parce que je
savais ce que c'était mais plus ou moins
c'est une responsabilité et je compte en
un hommage visuel et musical mis à la
disposition du public à la maison des
bonheurs de la ville pour ce premier
canon à l'unisson le maire a même
proposé aux élèves de revenir le
chantait à chaque commémoration du 8-mai
sécurité routière à présent mercredi
suite à la mort d'un motard non loin de
versailles des contrôles routiers ont
été renforcés durant le week-end de
l'ascension c'est le deuxième motard qui
trouve la mort sur nos routes depuis le
début de l'année des effectifs de police
sont donc déployés dans tout le
département pour faire de la prévention
routière le contrôle systématique des
deux roues est un événement rare
écoutez les explications de ce
déploiement spécifique au micro dé
michael et me d'euros c'est un détail
très important comme la météo par
exemple aujourd'hui et ces derniers
jours poussent
tout bon nombre de motocyclistes à
prendre la route
donc certains sont chevronnés et roule
tout l'hiver mais quand même
relativement peu et le danger c'est
souvent balles et les peler les jeunes
conducteurs ou alors les conducteurs qui
ne roulent pas forcément toute l'année
qui se mettent à cette saison à rouler
on est un peu au fort x et y fait beau
et c est le danger se rapproche beaucoup
plus vite que et nous avons parlé
maintenant mannequinat et mode c'est à
maurepas que des apprentis modèles se
sont réunis à l'occasion du fashion tour
une compétition nationale qui a décidé
de donner leur chance à des mannequins
de tous âges et de tous niveaux
les précisions de guillaume macaire et
michael et demi d'euros les mannequins
étaient à l'honneur ce week end à
maurepas la fashion tour grand casting
national de mode avait déroulé son tapis
rouge dans un centre commercial mort
d'asia
c'était l'occasion pour des apprentis
mannequins de défiler devant un jury
d'experts une première expérience qui se
veut avant tout formatrice l'achetant
vraiment que ses problèmes quand on voit
derrière au niveau du maquillage de la
coiffure on a des bons conseils sur les
tenues aussi donc on sent vraiment que
l'expérience derrière la compétition
était ouverte aux hommes et aux femmes à
partir de 16 ans il fallait s'inscrire
en ligne
les jeunes modèles sont avant tout les
passionnés ils voient dans ce fashion
tout un tremplin pour débuter une
carrière professionnelle
là tout ce que je veux c'est aller à
paris dans un premier temps et trouver
une agence super ici aujourd'hui je fais
toute la france il faut mais j'irai en
finale je il ya pas mal de gens qui ont
des a priori qui ont des petits crainte
on est là pour déjà les déstresser ici
c'est positif on n'est pas là pour
casser les jambes c'est vraiment une
première expérience il ya des
photographes professionnels ya des
coachs professionnels pour qu'on leur
donne des conseils
c'est une façon de se familiariser avec
l'univers de la mode la compétition
s'est étalée sur trois jours vincent
mcdoom a rejoint le jury
lors de la demi finale qui a vu quatre
modèles remporter leur place pour la
finale
il ya des débouchés il ya des boucs
photo il ya des contrats avec des
marques pour être égérie
voilà donc c'est une première expérience
pour certains c'est déjà une pas vers la
professionnalisation pour d'autres on
retrouvera donc d'orient et chloé en
novembre prochain à paris et peut-être
même plus tard sur les plus grands
podiums internationaux
merci et comme chaque lundi nous
retrouvons la chronique culturelle de
sephora namani bonsoir à sephora bonsoir
floral alors c'est sûr je vous présente
le portrait d'un artiste et vous laisse
deviner de qui il s'agit messieurs les
puits mafia deep lui docteur l'ebit a
mis à chanter je suis leur gynécologue
de votre femme elle-même en chaîne
mangas
mais non je n'ai pas aimé magnifique
mais les regards jeunes est punu
on porte une chaîne orouba
mon gros cul quoi
mon gros cul ma renaissance
bien sûr c'est pour elle c'était facile
de nexans et des sous-titrés il s'agit
du comédien et humoriste françois xavier
demaison très célèbre depuis son rôle
dans le film d'antoine de caunes coluche
l'histoire d'un mec qui est sorti en
tout à fait donc là ce que vous venez de
voir c'est un extrait de son deuxième
spectacle demaison s'évade et qui a fait
un triomphe et vendredi dernier xavier
demaison était à andrésy pour présenter
son tout nouveau spectacle demaison road
il nous en parle
j'ai l'impression que ces spectacles
plus personnel des trois le plus
efficace les 3 donc je suis vraiment
très très heureux de le jouer à chaque
fois c'est un bonheur c'est une tournée
magique quoi les gens sont debout c'est
la folie cela se passe on rit beaucoup
il ya beaucoup d'interactivité avec le
public et les moments de théâtre et des
moments vraiment où je joue avec le
public
il ya des moments où avec dimanche me
raconte sous forme de stand up c'est ça
on prendra tous ces styles alors un
spectacle multiples avec plus de
stand-up que dans les autres et puis
toujours des sketches avec une galerie
de personnages pour évoquer différents
thèmes tels que la politique l'écologie
pour interpeller le public est toujours
ce souci de faire réfléchir par le rire
alors nous n'avons pas pu avoir d'image
de ce tout nouveau spectacle car il a à
peine trente représentations depuis sa
sortie de résidence en janvier dernier
et la production ne souhaite pas encore
diffusé des images c'est encore un
spectacle top secret alors à cette
soirée était associé le rire médecin une
association parrainée par françois
xavier demaison depuis 2009 qui fait
intervenir des clowns professionnels
dont les services pédiatriques des
hôpitaux
cette cause me touche tout ce qui touche
à l'enfance me toucher une petite fille
et puis je trouve ça magnifique ses
clones qui vont dans les hôpitaux
divertir les enfants les faire oublier
qu'ils sont hospitalisés et puis danser
rires d'enfants il ya aussi une manière
pour l'enfant de montrer à ses parents
que c'est toujours un enfant que
voilà derrière la maladie à tout va bien
quoi alors deux maisons rodez donc son
troisième spectacle françois xavier
demaison a commencé d'ailleurs
relativement tard la comédie il me
semble oui tout à fait alors avec deux
parents avocat il s'est tourné plus ou
moins logiquement vers des études
juridiques et de science politique après
un bac littéraire tout en menant de
front quand même des études de comédie
car il avait la classe libre du cours
florent qui est considéré comme étant la
la classe le plus difficile et puis il
entame donc une carrière en 1998 comme
auditeur dans la fiscalité
internationale jusqu'à ce tragique jour
2 en septembre 2001 jour où il décide de
changer de vie
je crois que profondément je m'ennuyais
là où j'étais je faisais de la fiscalité
internationale à paris aux états unis et
je crois que ma place était sur scène
que je m'étais j'avais réfréner cette
passion puisqu'elle a ressurgit
aujourd'hui on septembre je me suis dit
que la vie était courte que le monde
était fou qu'il fallait être plus fou
que lui et que je voulais plus perdre ma
vie à la gagner
alors c'est froid quels seront les
prochains rendez-vous l'on pourra
espérer voir le spectacle de xavier
françois xavier demaison alors le
spectacle devait bien sûr poursuivre sa
tournée dans toute la france
dix dates en janvier 2007 à l'olympia
tout de même et c'est une grosse année
pour l'artiste car en septembre prochain
sortira en salles son film comment j'ai
rencontré mon père finn de maxime motte
avec isabelle carré
en décembre également vous pourrez le
retrouver en salle pour les têtes de
l'emploi un film d'alexandre charlot aux
côtés de franck dubosc et elsa
zylberstein mais avant cela très
prochainement le 22 juin précisément
vous pourrez le retrouver dans un film
de christophe barratier sur l' affaire
kerviel dont l'outsider
entré à la société générale c'est
rejoindre les meilleurs parmi les
meilleurs moyens à leurs traders qu'un
tel outil
l'esprit d'équipé avec une dernière
recommandation sortait il sentit pas qu
une noisette la 5 millions d'euros
imagine qu'on me demande de gagner 5 sur
l'année chaque trader si stratégie tout
ce que tu vas gagner en plus quand tu es
sur ton cru que dans ce cas bon merci
beaucoup sephora plus d'informations sur
la programmation de l'artiste à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bandeau en
bas de votre écran et avant de refermer
ce journal une dernière information
culturelle aujourd'hui lundi 9 mai a eu
lieu la réouverture de la galerie
déclare ross du château de versailles
fermé au public depuis 2007 la galerie a
vu sa surface d'exposition doublé elle
s'étend à présent sur plus de 1000
mètres carrés les précisions au micro de
sephora namani ça fait à peu près
maintenant un an que nous travaillons
sur cet immense chantier de la galerie
des carrosses c'est un chantier très
important parce que c'est une
réouverture pérenne d'un espace à
versailles ça on n'est pas du tout dans
le cadre d'une exposition éphémère et
donc on est ici comme on le voit dans
les bâtiments jules hardouin mansart
xviie siècle absolument super de ces
grandes écuries royales et reportages
sur cette inauguration à retrouver
demain dans le journal c'est la fin de
cette édition tout de suite vous
retrouver michael et demi d'euros pour
le cfid sport quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain et vous souhaite une
excellente soirée